OK, people, let's just get this
out of the way.
Now, I know this isn't a very comfortable
subject for many of you,
but I've got to say it.
We have to talk about your fungus problem.
Now, it's OK, don't be embarrassed.
You know who you are.
We can work this out.
We'll get through it together.
Now, call them fungi,
"fun-gee," "fun-guy" -- you decide.
But what I'd like to impress upon you
is this is a new world
we need to begin exploring.
And I think we can do it
in interesting ways.
But all of us have had an issue with fungi
at some point in our lives, right?
Maybe even now?
We think of fungi, we think of fuzzy stuff
that's growing on our yogurt
that we forgot in the back of the fridge.
Or maybe that itch you developed
by wearing that favorite pair of pants,
but just got a little bit too tight?
Or, you know, maybe you think
of death and decay and disease,
when you think about fungi?
But fungi, maybe some of them
have a dark side.
I mean, who of us doesn't?
But I'd like to invite you to see
these misunderstood creatures
in a new light,
and maybe start to appreciate
some of the positive
and inspirational ways that they behave.
So if that mold
is breaking bad on that yogurt
you forgot in the back
of the fridge, again,
maybe it's not just rotting and spoiling,
but maybe it's taking
an act of transformation,
of renewal and of new possibilities.
And it's that very act of transformation
that's so central to life on our planet,
it’s been important
for our own history.
And maybe for the future,
if we can learn from fungi,
we might be able to transform
ourselves and our societies
in ways that are in greater
harmony with nature.
So what do I mean when I say fungi
have been important to our past?
I'm not talking about that amazing
mushroom trip you took
back in university,
though that was probably
pretty awesome in its own right.
What I'm talking about is the way
that fungi have been central
to the evolution of life on the planet,
that virtually all life
has a fungal backstory.
Now, think: fungi have been on the planet
for a billion years ... or more.
And during that time the Earth
was just a rocky, desolate place.
There wasn't a lot of life on it.
Now, algae would actually
escape the waters
and come onto land
to evolve into land plants,
but only by partnering
with fungi first, as its root system.
Soils would begin to form
as fungi ate rock and broke it down
to make the nutrients available.
So you had this opportunity
for new life to spring up.
As a result, the evolution of plants
would explode across the planet,
which would oxygenate the atmosphere
and allow the evolution
of more complex life-forms,
like us, humans.
Right?
So being on the planet
for a billion years,
fungi have developed
all sorts of life strategies
to be adaptive and diverse and resilient.
Think about it --
they survived a billion years,
through great swings in climate,
over hundreds of millions of years,
lived through all the five
great mass extinction events,
where the dinosaurs went extinct
and the poor little trilobites
and countless other forms of life
that we don't even know existed.
But fungi persisted and thrived,
and do to this day.
And I think that's what drove them to me.
It's so endearing, right?
I mean, who doesn't love
a good survival story?
I know I do.
But fungi weren't my first love.
That was music, actually.
And actually, when I was
a young, young boy,
I was really into grunge music,
and I played in a grunge band.
And we were awful.
(Laughter)
But I didn't know that at the time,
and anyhow, I had to follow my passion.
So I put everything in my pickup truck
and I moved from my childhood home
of Kansas City to Seattle,
the mecca of grunge music in the ’90s.
And I was going to start a new band.
And unfortunately, none of the talent
of Nirvana or Soundgarden
rubbed off on me.
It would have been
a quite different life had it did.
But the splendor of the Pacific Northwest
forests really did.
And it was the trees
and all the life aboveground
that drew me there,
but it was the fungi
and the microbes belowground
that kept me coming back.
I just got even more and more interested
about the way that they lived,
all these bizarre forms,
the fact that fungi
are literally everywhere.
Right now, they're on your skin,
in your gut.
With every breath you take,
you inhale dozens of fungal spores.
Every move you make,
you trample mushrooms
and molds beneath your feet,
in the soil.
And their ubiquity ...
is a big reason why we know
so little about fungi.
Despite all the tools we have
at our disposal, scientific tools,
we know perhaps
five percent of all the fungi,
some three million species
that are thought to exist
in the world today.
Now that's a massive
amount of biodiversity
that we know virtually nothing about,
how it lives and what it does.
And that's what really inspired me
to continue to study about fungi
and ask deeper questions.
Could some of this biodiversity help
in creating a more resilient future?
What could we actually learn from fungi?
Were there metaphors that we might apply
to how we live,
to create a more resilient
future together?
I'd like to share with you
some of those metaphors.
The first is that fungi
are biointelligent.
Being on the planet for so long,
fungi have created a really great ability
to be good at resource efficiency
and resilience,
and, as it turns out, spatial planning.
So researchers in Japan
did this super cool experiment
where they wanted to see
if fungi could help engineers
to create more efficient
transport networks.
So they laid out oatmeal on a petri dish,
corresponding to the cities
of the Tokyo metropolitan area.
And they introduced a slime mold,
a type of fungus whose favoritest
food ever is oatmeal,
and the fungus rapidly went through
a process of self-optimization
to find the most efficient links
between its favoritest-ever food source,
represented by a map
of the Tokyo metropolitan area.
And in a matter of hours,
it would recreate, largely,
the existing railway map
of the Tokyo metropolitan area --
a process it took engineers
decades to actually produce.
Now the fungus, it has no brain,
it has no plan, it was given
no instructions or guidance.
But still, it created
a highly optimized network.
And this convinced me and other scientists
that maybe fungi
could have practical applications
to help solve some of our human challenges
in ways that are quick and efficient
and perhaps even more imaginative
than we could do
with all of our brains put together.
Now, another way that fungi
can produce a metaphor
is being collaborative.
Now, there is most evidence
in their relationship with plants.
Now remember how algae evolved into plants
through the help of fungi
as their root system?
Well, that love affair never ended.
Still today, 90 percent of all land plants
need to have a mycorrhizal association.
This is the plant-fungus-root association.
So depicted here,
in this highly realistic view
of the underground
of a forest ecosystem ...
you can see the fungus,
which exists in most of its life
as thin filaments,
and the network of thin filaments,
we call it mycelium.
And the mycelium of the fungus
can tap into the root of plants
and make a symbiosis.
And thereby, they exchange nutrients
that the other one isn't so good
at making or capturing.
So in case of the fungi,
they're providing minerals to the plants,
and the plants, through photosynthesis,
are providing carbon.
And so this exchange can go on
between the organisms.
But it doesn’t stop there,
because the fungi can tap
into other plants at the same time,
and other plants can also have
other fungal partners.
So what you end up with
is this massive underground network
mediated by fungi.
Now, it's not just nutrients
that are flowing,
but also communication,
because plants can talk to each other
through the fungal network
to create chemical signals to be able
to warn of a pest attack, for example.
Now, fungi are also regenerative.
Now, their ability to decompose
is important for the planet,
to say the least,
because fungi eat death
and give it back to life, as nutrients,
to start the cycle anew.
In nature, there's no such thing as waste.
I mean, waste is a human concept.
Everything is used,
everything is circular.
Everything becomes something else.
And if you don't appreciate fungi,
you will, for one reason,
and it's that decompositional ability.
I mean, think about it.
We would be buried under kilometers
of undecayed plant matter
and dead animals and poo
without the decompositional
ability of fungi.
And that would be
a pretty crappy existence,
you've got to admit.
So as a metaphor,
fungi can provide us
with ways of being biointelligent,
collaborative and resilient.
But I also believe that fungi
have practical applications
in how we produce materials.
And this is actually my very cool day job,
as researcher at a fermentation science
company here in Oslo
that’s reimagining a new world
of more sustainable materials
of everyday products.
So let me give you some examples.
One is biomaterials.
So taking a fungus,
we can literally grow new materials,
using agricultural residues,
to replace unsustainable products
like Styrofoam or Rockwool
that often end up
in landfills or in pollution.
So we can grow things
like soundproofing panels
or insulation for buildings.
Or we can make mushroom Frisbees.
The possibilities are nearly endless.
We can also make textiles from fungi.
So, for example, animal-free leathers.
So usually, you have a cow,
and it takes about three years
to make leather,
and all the resources
and animal death that is involved.
Not a great way to make leather.
If you can make it another way,
like with fungi,
it takes days to make it.
A much better way
that's both efficient and ethical,
and how we can make leathers
in the future.
And then, there's food,
a subject I'm particularly
passionate about.
Now, with fungi, we can make
a whole range of sustainable
and delicious foods.
Things like meat replacements
for seafood or dairy, for example.
Or even a new class of food
that doesn't look like any of that stuff.
The possibilities are unlimited.
And we can do it in a way
that has a fraction
of the environmental footprint.
Now fungi are self-replicating organisms,
so we can make it
in really huge quantities,
and help address the challenge
of how we're going to make more food
and lower our impact on the planet.
It's a big challenge.
We can do it with fungi.
And last but not least, fish feed.
I mean, here we are in Norway, right?
The world's largest producer of salmon.
And what do we feed
that salmon, as proteins?
Two things, primarily --
soy and fish meal,
neither of which are sustainable
sources of protein for the future,
because they contribute
to overfishing in the oceans
and land-use patterns that degrade,
for some of the lands.
So we need to come up
with more sustainable sources
in how we feed our fish.
And what if we could do it using fungi
to create the proteins to feed those fish?
And we could do it in a way
that we’re using byproducts
of food industries
as food for our fungus when we grew it?
It would be an amazingly
sustainable system
and, dare I say it, it would help
in our self-sufficiency.
Now, one of the coolest things
about being a fungal researcher
is, with all that diversity out there,
probably the coolest thing
that fungi can do,
we haven't even uncovered yet.
The most amazing fungal discoveries
are still waiting to be made.
We're only scratching the surface
of what we might be able to achieve
with the help of fungi.
So I have a hope,
and my hope is that we transfer
our fungal problems
into fungal solutions,
that we look to the fungal world
for new mindsets and new metaphors
and even new materials,
as we think more
collaboratively, regeneratively
and with more biointelligence,
as we approach the future,
just like fungi.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)